people who are surrounded with when we
grow up it's very unlikely just from a
population standpoint that they're going
to be great do you know thousands of
people when you're a kid probably not
you probably know five or six so
statistically that they're going to be
the top one percent or point one percent
is unlikely so it would make sense that
you change your friends over time now if
you were able to somehow by The Stroke
of luck and God and whatever be able to
find people who also had the same dreams
and goals as you and comma we're willing
to pay the price because this is
something that I love from James Clare
winners and losers have the same goals
everybody wants a six-pack the goal
doesn't make you unique it's the
willingness to pay the price that makes
you unique